au menu ce midi rôti de porc purée et
foie de veau maître d'hôtel depuis ce
matin la cuisine tourne à plein régime
la fin d'une longue attente pour fabrice
ça fait vraiment du bien
sincèrement ça fait trois mois qu'on non
même si on était fermés ou travailler
pour remettre le restaurant au goût du
jour pour l'essai de se réinventer et ça
fait vraiment du bien de voir les
voitures passaient et volets s'ouvrent
et on a tout nettoyé on est prêts on les
attend
l'accueil des clients se fera dans les
règles fléchage au sol tables espacées à
un mètre de distance par des plexiglas
une cinquantaine de couverts sont
attendus pour cette reprise
cette matin heureusement plane
entreprises qui demandent si nous sommes
ouvertes
c'est quelqu'un de ma venue à nos deux
familles en à des tableaux mais on peut
mettre ensemble ou des gens qui assemble
que seul un peu mis dans un petit coucou
il va santé en toute sécurité
ici la musique irlandaise va de nouveau
résonné en salle pour cette réouverture
les clients auront même le privilège
d'avoir quelques pas de danse au menu
[Rires]